nous voici dans le jardin d'un
particulier encore une fois à osmois
près de Toir ce que vous venez de voir
ce sont des grandes perruches mais nous
ne sommes pas là pour ça ce qui nous
intéresse c'est ce qu'il y a derrière
moi la serre attention ça pique vous
allez
voir jacquagne bonjour merci de nous
recevoir ici bonjour alors la première
chose qu'on se dit en arrivant dans
cette ser et que s'est-il passé il y a
eu une invasion de cactus ici bah
c'est-à-dire que quand on vous offre
deux trois petites plantes 8 10 cm ben
il y a deux cas hein le premier bon on y
par pas grande attention et puis on
abandonne au bout de quelques temps et
puis la deuxième on s'y intéresse un peu
plus particulièrement et puis bah après
on souhaite peut-être avoir une
documentation et puis pourquoi pas
encore trois quatre plantes et puis ça
finit c'est un début de collection avec
10 12 petites plantes et on se fabrique
une petite tablette parce queon est en
appart et puis on essaie de faire vivre
ses plant vous avez commencé il y a
combien de temps vous 54 ans il y a 54
ans oui ça me rason pas mais il faut
faire avec et céit un cadeau comment ça
a commencé oui c'est ma femme qui
m'avait à l'occasion d'alité une grippe
je sais plus trop quoi elle m'avait
amené du marché trois petits cactus en
petit pot petits pot comme ça et puis en
pu aujourd'hui on a une s de 70 m²
rempli de partout voilà alors bon il y a
eu quand même beaucoup d'étapes je suis
ici enfin ma femme depuis 20 ans oui
tout ce qui est central c'est en pleine
terre et comme en pays d'origine c'est
relativement des arbres bah ça fait des
monstres s'il se plaisent alors il y en
a qui abandonnent he celui-là il se
plaît bien par exemple celui-là il a
énormément grandi parce que quand il est
arrivé ici il y a 20 ans il faisait à
peu près cette là c'est tout ça demande
beaucoup de soins est-ce que ça demande
beaucoup de soins à cactus alors
beaucoup de
surveillance un petit coup tous les tous
les jours tous les deux jours au besoin
mais la surveillance compte plus un coup
de quoi de l'eau d'œil un coup d'œil
alors
l'eau c'est à la belle saison on va dire
du printemps à l'automne on mouille
copieusement mais on Nisse pas ces
arrosages faut se rappeler qu'en pays
d'origine ce sont des orages c'est pas
le crachin que l'on a par ici
c'est-à-dire que quand il pleut il pleut
carrément 10 15 20 cm et après on attend
un mois 2 mois et cetera et l'hiver
pratiquement plus rien moi il reste euh
4 mois 4 mois et demi plus une goutte
d'eau parce que ces plantes ont les
cellules qui s'en trouvent la nuit
captent l'hygrométrie atmosphérique et
survivent avec ça est-ce que vous avez
des variétés un petit peu rares ici
comment vous les comment d'où elles
viennent vos plantes en fin de compte
alors avant la Convention de Washington
là en 79 ou quelque chose comme ça oui
euh on pouvait ramener des plantes en
pays d'origine et en ce qui me concerne
j'ai beaucoup voyagé dans les pays où il
y avait alors essentiellement
euh États-Unis Californie Arizona euh
tout tout le sud des États-Unis
finalement le Mexique euh tenerif il y
en a aussi bon les les îles par là c'est
vous qui avez été leschercher euh ah oui
oui carrément oui oui en faant des
voyages de vacances et bien ça se
transformait un peu en expédition avec
le chapeau de cowboy et puis le véhicule
un peu toute piste et puis vous vous
arrêtiez vous dites ah celui-là je le
veux dans ma serre euh quand c'était
possible oui vous avez des variétés un
petit peu rares ici il y en a
quelques-unes j'en ai perdu aussi je
dois être honnête mais comme tout
collectionneur hein euh j'ai certaines
variétés qui sont euh assez c'est rare
en l'occurrence là il y a un spécimen là
qui surtout à cette toil là fait partie
des plantes àe je DIRIS pasque qu'est-ce
que c'est alors c'est un
locreux
chti d'accord ah c'est tous des noms à
la bizarre mais bon voilà qu'est-ce qui
vous plaît vous dans les
cactus
l'originalité j'aime pas les choses
standard toutes bête qu'on voit partout
tout c'est un peu un avantage et un
défaut donc dans les cactuses et les
plantes grosse parce que je dois dire
qu'il y a une majorité de Forbes si vous
voulez les plantes succulentes c'est une
grande famille une énorme famille
là-dedans il y a deux grandes branches
les cactus les plantes grasses et dans
les plantes grosses vous avez plein de
sortes de fores plus d'autres plantes
grasses et cetera et dans les cactuses
vous avez toutes les formes des
cylindres des oreilles de Miquet des
oponcias
euh des des boules des globuleuses des
féraux des des marinariat enfin beaucoup
de beaucoup de variétés de géométrie
très très
différentes merci beaucoup pour toutes
ces informations mais c'était avec
plaisir si ça pu vous intéresser et si
je vous dit jardin mandala vous voyez de
quoi je parle non et bien regardez ce
reportage vous verrez ce n'est pas si
compliqué
ce jardin a l'air en friche mais ne vous
y trompez pas il a été designé et pensé
selon le principe des potagers mandala
mandala en fait ça veut dire ronde en
sanscrit c'est un jardin qui un potager
qui est ronde au lieu de le jardin en
carré ou le jordin en rang tout droit on
essaie de de faire des plantations avec
les plantes qui sentend bien ensemble
donc les plantes compignent et aussi on
se rend compte une fois qu'on est dans
le jardin ça travaille beaucoup plus
efficacement en fait on n pas besoin de
marcher si loin pour aroser ni pour
trouver un efficacité et surtout
interaction positive entre les plantes
le maïs la courge et le haricot par
exemple forment un trio complémentaire
l'un protège les autres des nuisible
tandis que les essences dégagées par
l'un profitent aux deux autres c'est un
des principes de la permaculture une
alternative aux méthodes de jardinage
traditionnel respectueuse de
l'environnement au jardin de cocane de
manilé à l'association en transition a
installé son jardin pédagogique il y a
tout juste un an moi j'aime beaucoup
l'idée du jardin
mandala maintenant la mise en œuvre on
la vit au quotidien donc c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement curieux et
d'extrêmement novateur parmi les règles
à respecter l'absence de pesticides
l'utilisation de variétés anciennes mais
aussi la mise en valeur de mauvaises
herbes qui sont souvent comestible voire
médicinal l'association compte 60
familles adhérentes qui se rencontrre
tous les weekends autour de ce jardin
circulaire nous sommes dans une ferme un
peu spéciale à saint-rémis les
chevreuses Cédric Péchard cultive depuis
6 mois des champignons des pleurottes de
manière écologique vous allez comprendre
comment Cédric Péchard bonjour bonjour
merci de nous recevoir dans ce container
alors pourquoi un container d'abord
alors en fait ici c'est une unité de
production agricole autonome donc le
conttainur en soi c'est un module qu'on
va pouvoir transporter et il y a un mois
il était encore au milieu de Paris et là
maintenant il est ici dans un site
complètement agricole donc il y avait
une logique à à l'installer ici ce que
vous produisez donc ici ce sont des
pleurot il y en a plein partout à
différents stades ou vous pouvez n mon
ça donc là on voit différents stades
effectivement de maturation là des
jeunes des jeunes
pouss ici elles ont à peu près une
semaine et dans dans 2 jours elles
seront prêtes à être récolté combien
vous en produisez vous par mois par
semaine alors un un container produit 15
kg par jour de pleurotte toute l'année
quelle que soit la météo externe mais si
on en met 10 à côté ben on a tout de
suite un gros volume de production ce
qui est l'intérêt des contenurs c'est
d'être très modulaire très modulable
dans le dans la production si votre
entreprise est qualifié d'écologique
c'est pour une raison alors
effectivement en fait à la base c'est
pas un projet uniquement de production
de champignons c'est un projet de
montage d'une filière de collecte de M
de café donc c'est une filière de
collecte régionale sur l'Île-de-France
et on va transformer ce Mar de café qui
est pasteurisé par les distributeurs de
café les machines automatiques en fait
pasteurisent le café et font de la
collecte de ce marc de café et vous ce
marc de café vous l'utilisez voilà donc
on on le récupère comme substrat pour
cette production de de champignon c'est
bon le mar de café pour les pleurottes
c'est excellent c'est excellent ça nous
permet d'avoir un produit
beaucoup plus charnu beaucoup qui a
beaucoup moins d'eau beaucoup plus de
goût et une texture que les
restaurateurs apprécient énormément
merci beaucoup je en prie leur jardin ce
sont les plaines ou encore les bois pour
ces passionnés de botanique les
mauvaises herb deviennent des
ingrédients à haute valeur ajouté
reportage avecod
morodisiaque
para magicien le gourou de cette troupe
en chaussures de marche est venu
dispenser ses conseils au Jardin de
Cocagne de manilamo samedi au menu et à
toutes les sauces les plantes sauvages
beaucoup prennent des notes certains des
photos les autres boivent littéralement
ses paroles et même les connaisseurs
font des découvertes alors LIF moi dans
ma campagne étant enfant c'était l'arbre
à ne pas toucher et aujourd'hui bien on
me dit que les baies rouges sont
comestibles
c'est voilà 63 ans c'est une
première et bien souvent les plantes
sauvages sont autant médicinal que
gustative des allicaments qui datent de
milliers
d'années grande consoude là en
particulier pour les contusion et ce les
traumatismes c'est intéressant ça
m'arrive souvent donc voilà ça c'est
très très intéressant pour ça
effectivement à la vapeur je préfère
mais cru ça passe à merveille
véritement en vapeur en plasme en
infusion ou en canapé pour eux les
herbes folles deviennent des trésors à
la découverte d'un patrimoine discret
connu de nos ancêtres depuis la
préhistoire mais oublié de la plupart
d'entre nous
aujourd'hui le but de comprendre que
l'on pied taille très souvent dans son
jardin une carte des menus extrêmement
exhaustive pour parler de manière
pompeuse mais effectivement les
mauvaiseses n'existent pas et laab
lortil P en lit par exemple sont bien
plus nutritionnels que la viande tout
simplement aussi j'ai vu un mélange
mi c'est remarable c'est vraiment
gustativement mais incomparable
viment toute l'année l'association Sky
en transition propose des visites des
ateliers ou encore des
piquequs voilà ce tour des jardins est
maintenant terminé n'oubliez pas que
vous pouvez aussi ne rien faire dans
votre coin de verdure et comme moi culti
votre jardin intérieur bonne été sur TVF